ROLE.
>> THEY'RE CATCHING UP, THE
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T VOTE IN THE
SECOND BALLOT.
I WANT TO TALK TO MANU RAJU WHO
JUST SPOKE WITH ONE OF THE 19
REBELS, CONGRESSMAN CHIP ROY,
REPUBLICAN, OF TEXAS.
WHO VOTED FOR A COLLEAGUE OF HIS
FROM FLORIDA ON THE FIRST VOTE
AND VOTED FOR JIM JORDAN ON THE
SECOND, MANU, WHAT DID HE HAVE
TO SAY.
>> HE'S NOT MOVING OFF HIS
OPPOSITION OR ALIGNING HIMSELF
WITH A NUMBER OF CONSERVATIVE
MEMBER, HARD-LINERS WHO WANT A
NUMBER OF DEMANDS TO STRENGTHEN
THE RANK AND FILE, WEAKEN THE
SPEAKERSHIP, THINGS THAT KEVIN
McCARTHY SAYS HE ALREADY HAS
AGREED TO BUT ROY MAKING CLEAR
TO ME THAT HE IS ALMOST
CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO BE IN THE
McCARTHY CAMP.
>> THE PEOPLE OF THE TABLE AND
THE RULES COMMITTEE OR
OTHERWISE -- GUARANTEE THAT WILL
ENFORCE THE RULES WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT.
BY THE WAY, EVERYBODY IN THAT
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS MEETING THIS
MORNING SAID, OH, WE LIKE THE
RULES, GOOD JOB, CHIP, YOU GUYS
WORKED HARD FOR THE RULES AND
THEN AT THE END THEY SAID BUT IF
YOU DON'T VOTE FOR McCARTHY,
WE'RE GOING TO GET RID OF THE
RUES.
IT'S A GAME.
THAT'S THE GAME AND ACTUALLY PUT
A QUOTE ON THE BOARD THAT SAID
SOMETHING IN THE ZIP CODE OF,
HEY, FOR THE PART OF TRYING TO
PUT PEOPLE ON THE COMMITTEE WITH
DIVERSE VIEWS AND KEVIN SAID
THAT BUT A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM DIDN'T WANT THAT.
>> SO WHAT HE'S REFERRING TO IS
A MORNING MEETING THAT OCCURRED
TODAY IN WHICH KEVIN McCARTHY
TRIED TO URGE, TO ESSENTIALLY
ARM TWIST THESE MEMBERS INTO
SUPPORTING HIM.
THAT CLEARLY BACKFIRED FOR
PEOPLE LIKE CHIP ROY SAYING
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY ARE
SUGGESTING, THEIR THREATS AND
THE LIKE DID NOT WIN THEM OVER,
IN FACT, GREW THE OPPOSITION,
HAD THE OPPOSITE EFFECT THAT
McCARTHY AND HIS ALLIES HAD
WANTED BUT McCARTHY'S ALLIES ARE
INDICATING THEY ARE NOT MOVING
EITHER.
I JUST TALKED TO CONGRESSMAN
MIKE LAWLER, INCOMING
CONGRESSMAN WHO TOLD ME IF IT
GOES TO 50 BALLOTS HE PLANS TO
STICK WITH KEVIN McCARTHY FOR 50
BALLOTS, HE SAID OF THOSE
CONSERVATIVE FOES WHAT IS THEIR
END GAME?
WE'LL KEEP VOTING AND VOTING AND
GUESS WHAT, WE -- THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH VOTES AND WE
OUTWEIGH THEM SO THAT'S THE
QUESTION HERE, JAKE.
WHO WILL BLINK FIRST?
RIGHT NOW McCARTHY ALLIES ARE
SAYING THEY WON'T DO IT AND
NEITHER WILL THE CONSERVATIVES
AND WILL THERE BE SOME SORT OF
CONSENSUS?
AT THE MOMENT NO CONSENSUS
CANDIDATE.
KEVIN McCARTHY, 19 VOTES AGAINST
HIM RIGHT NOW.
HE NEEDS TO KEEP THAT ONLY TO
FOUR.
UNCLEAR WHEN OR IF IT WILL
HAPPEN.
>> WE HEARD MANU TALKING TO
CONGRESSMAN CHIP ROY WHO SEEMED
TO SUGGEST HE'S NOT BLINKING.
I GOT A TEXT, ABBY PHILLIP, FROM
1 OF THE 203 VITING FOR KEVIN
McCARTHY SAYING HE'LL GET THE
VOTE.
WE'RE NOT BLINKING EITHER.
>> TO BE FAIR, HALLMARK OF THIS
GROUP OF 19 AND THE FOLKS WHO
ARE KIND OF LEADING THIS CHARGE
IS THAT IT'S ALL ABOUT THROWING
A WRENCH IN THE MACHINE BUT NOT
ACTUALLY SOLVING ANY PROBLEMS,
WHO IS THE ALTERNATIVE?
NO ONE HAS REALLY EMERGED WHO
WILL ACTUALLY HAVE A SHOT OF
GETTING TO 218.
I THINK THAT THAT -- IT IS FAIR
TO PUT THE ONUS ON THE NEVER
McCARTHYS AND SAY WHO?
WHO IS THE PERSON WHO IS GOING
TO GET THERE?
OTHERWISE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
VOTING ALL NIGHT AND MAYBE
TOMORROW UNTIL NEXT YEAR, UNTIL
SOMEONE ELSE EMERGES IF IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE McCARTHY.
>> HERE'S THE CHALLENGE IF
YOU'RE PART OF THE WHAT I WOULD
REFER TO AS THE GOVERNING WING,
NOT NECESSARILY MODERATE BUT
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY WANT TO GET
STUFF DONE, RIGHT NOW JIM JORDAN
IS SITTING IN THAT WING, THE
CHALLENGE IS ALWAYS THAT THOSE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY DO WANT TO SEE
THINGS HAPPEN.
THEY WANT TO BRING DELIVERABLES
HOME TO THEIR DISTRICT.
THAT'S WHAT THEIR VOTERS ARE
DEMANDING IF YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN
IN A BIDEN DISTRICT, THAT'S WHAT
THEY NEED TO GET RE-ELECTED.
THOSE PEOPLE ULTIMATELY WILL
HAVE MORE OF AN INCENTIVE TO END
THIS, I MEAN, I ALMOST SWORE
RIGHT THERE TO END THIS SHOW,
YOU FILL IN THE BLANK THAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE HOUSE FLOOR
BECAUSE THEY HAVE POLITICAL
INCENTIVES THAT LINE UP WITH
ENDING IT AND FINDING A SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE.
THESE 19 PEOPLE AND THIS HAS
BEEN THE PROBLEM WITH DEALING
WITH THE FREEDOM CAUCUS FROM,
YOU KNOW, JOHN BOEHNER TO PAUL
RYAN RIGHT ON DOWN TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY IS THAT THEY DO NOT
SEEM TO CARE ABOUT THAT PIECE OF
IT.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT GOVERNING.
THEIR SELF-INTERESTS -- YOU'VE
HEARD NARCISSIST BEING USED BY
MANY OF THEIR OPPONENTS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TODAY, THEY
CARE ABOUT AS JOHN HAS SAID
APPEARING ON RIGHT WING RADIO.
WHAT IS THEIR PROFILE?
THE LEVERAGE AND THE WAYS THAT
LEADERSHIP USED TO HAVE TO GET
CONTROL OF PEOPLE LIKE THESE 19
ARE BASICALLY GONE AND THAT
MEANS THAT FOR THEM, YOU KNOW,
SITTING HERE AND DOING THIS 50
TIMES, WHO CARES?
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY SKIN IN THAT
GAME NECESSARILY WHEREAS ALL
THESE PEOPLE SITTING WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY, THEY ACTUALLY DO AND
MAY GET TO A POINT WHERE THEY
HAVE TO SAY WE GOT TO MAKE A
CHANGE.
>> THIS McCARTHY ALLY JUST SENT
THIS TO ME.
A QUOTE FROM CONGRESSMAN GUY
REFRESH REFRESHEN THAT YOU
WILLER.
IF THEY THINK IT WILL BE A GAME
OF CHICKEN THEY WILL BE SADLY
SURPRISED.
WE'LL BE HERE TILL FOURTH OF
JULY VOTING FOR McCARTHY.
>> THAT'S THE THING.
THEY FEEL IF THEY BACK DOWN
THEY'RE GIVING IN TO THESE 19
BUT THE FIVE AND THE NINE.
WE'LL TAKE ONE VOTE OR A
HUNDRED.
WE'LL KEEP GOING UNTIL WE ELECT
A SPEAKER.
FULLY COMMITTED TO THAT.
KEVIN McCARTHY IS NOT BACKING
DOWN FROM THIS AND WE SHOULD
NOTE IN THAT TENSE MEETING WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS, MIKE
ROGERS SAID THEY WOULD REMOVE
THEM FROM THEIR COMMITTEES.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY CARE.
>> THEY DON'T CARE BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE PART OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WITH CONCESSIONS
IS WHAT THE COMMITTEE MAKEUP
LOOKS LIKE AND HOW MANY MEMBERS
OF THE HOUSE FREEDOM CAUCUS ARE
ON CERTAIN COMMITTEES.
>> McCARTHY SAID HE WOULD GIVE
THEM MORE OR LESS WHAT THEY
WANTED AND THEY DON'T WANT THAT.
>> STILL SAID NO.
>> SOME OF THOSE MEMBERS HAVE
SAID ON THE RECORD, IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT KEVIN McCARTHY
OFFERS US, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
TAKE IT AND I THINK TO KASIE'S
POINT, THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM
HERE IS THAT THERE IS A HUGE
PORTION OF THE REPUBLICAN BASE
THAT IS NOT INTERESTED IN ANY
WAY, SHAPE OR FORM IN ANYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON.
THE WHOLE POINT IS TO RABBLE
ROUSE, TO STICK IT TO THE OTHER
SIDE, TO, YOU KNOW, THROW OUT
RED MEAT AND AS LONG AS THAT'S
THE INCENTIVE STRUCTURE IT'S
REALLY HARD IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
HAND OUT SOME CARROTS WHEN
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN OFFER
THEM THAT WILL BE GOOD ENOUGH.
>> THIS IS A GROUP WHO WANTS TO
BURN IT DOWN.
KEVIN OFFERED THEM EVERYTHING,
AND THEY SAID NO.
THEY DON'T WANT IT.
I ALSO THINK WE SHOULD TALK
ABOUT FORMER CONGRESSMAN RODNEY
DAVIS TALKED ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GET TIRED
AND THEY'RE GOING TO STEP UP.
NONSENSE.
>> OH, NO, THEY LOVE THIS.
>> NONSENSE.
>> THE HAPPIEST PEOPLE ON THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE.
>> ALL DAY, ALL NIGHT AND, YOU
KNOW, THE ONLY QUESTION IN MY
MIND, SOMEONE SAID TO ME, WHO'S
HAPPIER RIGHT NOW, NANCY PELOSI
OR LIZ CHENEY?
AND I THINK THAT --
>> A GREAT QUESTION.
>> IT'S A GOOD QUESTION BUT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SITTING IN, YOU
KNOW, THE BEST SEAT AND THIS IS
NOT UP TO THEM.
>> YEAH.
>> IT'S UP TO KEVIN McCARTHY AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE MORE
THING, CHIP ROY STARTED THIS
PROCESS NOT AS ONE OF THE FIVE
NEVER KEVINS.
>> NO, HE WAS ONE OF THE NINE
KEVIN SKEPTICS.
>> HE WAS TRYING TO NEGOTIATE.
HE THOUGHT THIS COULD BE DONE
BEFORE CHRISTMAS.